el medio de la exuberante selva y los
manglares al borde del océano Pacífico
se encuentran embarcaciones que no lucen
como barcos tradicionales parecen estar
fuera de lugar son vestigios de una
guerra despiadada llevada a cabo por la
marina colombiana eso es un artefacto
naval tipo semisumergible
contra Los contrabandistas que usan
estos submarinos para transportar drogas
[Música]
personal a su disposición mi Coronel
vistafren Cómo funciona la cadena del
narcotráfico partimos con esta unidad de
Infantería de Marina hacia el sur de la
selva colombiana
mundial
el barco navega por el río lo más
silenciosamente posible el equipo está
buscando pistas que los acerquen a Los
contrabandistas
avance el espacio los dos ametralladores
pendientes de los dos costados
la geografía de esta parte de Colombia
es una geografía que se presta para dos
actividades primero para poder cultivar
la cocaína porque son sitios inhóspitos
son sitios alejados pero al mismo tiempo
para poderla procesar y poderla sacar al
mercado ilegal cuando los soldados ven
algo desembarcan y se adentran en la
selva el peligro es real porque los
cárteles se defienden hoy los soldados
se encuentran con una base secreta que
Los contrabandistas parecen haber
abandonado a toda prisa es un mini
Astillero y este submarino está
prácticamente listo para salir
el suelo está lleno de materiales
utilizados para construirlo fibra de
vidrio para el casco pintura especial
motores de barco equipos que pueden ser
costosos el artefacto es un
semisumergible el valor aumenta
alrededor de los 700 mil dólares pero el
kilo oscila entre los 33 mil dólares
puesto en Estados Unidos entonces la
capacidad de carga estamos hablando de
que es entre dos 2000 y 3000 kilos ahí
tenemos una ganancia considerable cuando
no son interceptados en tierra Los
contrabandistas parten en submarinos
hacia Centroamérica y principalmente a
México allí entregan su carga a los
cárteles que organizan su paso a Estados
Unidos
[Música]
marinos colombianos y estadounidenses
trabajan juntos para detenerlos como en
esta espectacular captura en alta mar
[Música]
y la base naval de tumaco los militares
exhiben sus ganancias de guerra este
tipo de embarcaciones empezaron a
aparecer hace 20 años después de que los
cárteles contrataran a ingenieros rusos
para enseñarles a construirlos algunos
son verdaderos submarinos capaces de
sumergirse hasta una profundidad de unos
10 metros con una tripulación de 3 a 5
personas en el primer compartimento en
la parte delantera encontramos el
espacio para la carga ilícita hay un
compartimento en el que se ubicaría el
piloto y la tripulación en la parte
posterior encontraríamos los motores que
en este momento pues ya no están dentro
del dentro del artefacto pero la mayoría
de Los buques son semisumergibles pueden
Navegar justo por encima del nivel del
mar la posición en las que ellos en la
que ellos van a navegar es siempre de
pie y con la cabeza por fuera del
artefacto para poder ver Hacia dónde
están navegando básicamente
cada día Acostas se entrenan para
detener no solo a los submarinos sino
también a las lanchas rápidas las
embarcación elegida por Los
contrabandistas Este es el guardacostas
la armada Calcula que intercepta más de
la mitad de las 1.200 toneladas de
cocaína que se producen en Colombia cada
año